the only memory I have of that is  putting myself in a kind of Trance  trance-like State because I was in a  cocked up State as the character so I  found myself every day going into this  room with all these guns and all the  smoke and all this hell actually and I  would put myself in some kind of a give  myself a kind of Mantra and just go in  bite the bullet and you know spend the  12-14 hours there every day  day in and day out of just shooting that  sequence  did you find that you get into a rhythm  and if you're relaxed when you're doing  it  you can take anything you get Zen about  it  because if you for once take a look  around you it's uh it's just unendurable